we have a voicemail number that you can
call absolutely anytime recently you may
remember that Lauren bobert the radical
republican congresswoman
um spoke very positively about the fact
that she's going to be a grandmother
despite only being 36 years old and
acted like this is a great thing the
Eggman and I by the way I told you all
the reasons why outcomes are way worse
when the younger mothers are
um the worse the outcomes are for the
kids in the United States in so many
different measures the Eggman called in
and he has a different perspective that
he believes is important to consider
hey Dave I'm calling about Lauren
bulbert Taylor green whatever her name
is the one that's bragging about being a
36 year old grandparent
um Dave I know we're putting her down
for that and and it is deplorable but
Jews are like two percent of the whole
entire population not even actually way
less than that I feel like Jews don't
even have children until we're in our
30s and we only have like one or two so
do you think that just the ideology of
being responsible parent taking care of
your children is going to make the Jews
and
um just smart liberals die out do you
think liberals need to just spread their
seed more and be less caring about
reproduction if you want to keep our
liberal moral agenda going or our Jewish
Heritage going for that matter
Shalom brother oh yeah have you ever
heard of a 36 year old Jewish
grandparents I'm 20 years older than her
and I'm not a grandparent yet so very
very that's very true and I I have a
nine month old so no there's a the
Eggman so the eggman's using a lot of
hyperbole among other things but he is
bringing up an interesting issue which
is the fact that Lauren bobert and in
many parts of the country among folks
like Lauren bobert
teen pregnancy is seen as a great thing
and abortion is seen as a bad thing it
leads to grandmothers in their 30s and
it leads to this hegemonic nature of
they are having so many more kids they
are more likely to end up being right
Wingers they are crowding out
liberal values and that is a concern I
mean when you it's true that the more
educated one is the later they they have
kids and the fewer kids they have it's
true that the wealthier one is on
average the more you wait to have kids
and you have fewer kids and it is also
the case
that I mean to talk about the Jewish
Community the Jewish Community is
overwhelmingly liberal it's arguably the
most liberal voting Block in the United
States other than black Americans and
it's right up there
um ultra-orthodox Jews have a ton of
kids much like Mormons do or Evangelical
Christians but that is a very small
percentage of of Jewish folks and so the
Eggman is not wrong in anything that he
is saying but
I don't know that bobert cheering being
a 36 year old grandmother makes me say
it's time to start having a whole bunch
of kids that that doesn't uh follow for
me but an interesting subject
nonetheless let me know your thoughts
we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access I look forward to
seeing you there it's going to be a
great bonus show everybody but we'll be
back tomorrow otherwise